toujours dans la page de l'écho après le
microcrédit dont nous parlions il ya
quelques instants avant ce reportage
consacré à renault clair nous évoquons
maintenant une avec une nouvelle invitée
le concours talents de la création de la
belgique et oui les inscriptions sont
ouvertes c'est la quinzième édition
alors céline cassis vous êtes
conseillère en création d'entreprise à
l'abg divine sud
c'est votre organisme qui l'organisme et
le but finalement c'est d'encourager des
entreprises qui viennent de se créer
c'est ça tout à fait le but de ce
concours en fait c'est de mettre en
avant des porteurs de projets qui
viennent de créer leur entreprise mais
également de mettre en avant
l'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise qu'on pense c'est une
valeur en tout cas cher à la butte j'ai
eu des yvelines enfin les jeux eux-mêmes
tout court en france de mettre en avant
l'accompagnement parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'un projet accompagné accompagnés a
beaucoup plus de chances de durer dans
le temps si on peut parler en quelques
statistiques une entreprise après près
sur quatre n'existe plus une entreprise
sur deux parcs on n'existe plus au bout
de sa de quatre ans alors qu'une
entreprise accompagné au bout de quatre
ans elle existe encore à peu près à 70%
donc d'où le fait de mettre en avant
l'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise alors le but c'est aussi
donc de médiatiser c'est entre ces
petites entreprises oui tout à fait oui
donc le concours à des dotations
financières et numéraire d'un point de
vue régional et national mais a
également un but de médiatiser ces
petites entreprises parce qu'on sait
également des petites entreprises qu'on
accompagne pour les mettre en avant ou
après débats des mets des différents
médias que ce soit régionaux locaux ou
voir même nationaux petite question bg e
pour l'introduction ça signifie quoi
c'est en fait les ex boutique de gestion
donc on a changé de nom il ya un peu
plus d'un an et maintenant s'appelle les
bg e donc
tout département à son bg e et non du
département derrière donc pour nous
c'est l'abbé géodésie line
alors si vous parliez donc d'être
financière également qu'est ce
qu'apporte ce concours donc le concours
apporte au niveau régional à peu près
des primes 2000 à 3000 euros donc que ça
soit en numéraire ou en nature donc ça
peut être également de l'accompagnement
du conseil est également tout l'aspect
médiatique et au niveau national ça va
de 4000 à 8000 euros pour pour celui qui
remporte ce trophée
alors pour ceux qui souhaiteraient y
participer c'est juste que quand et
quels sont les conditions pour y
participe alors les deux conditions pour
y participer c'est d'une part d'avoir
créé son entreprise où sa société au
courant de l'année 2012 et jusqu'à mars
2013 de cette année et la deuxième
condition c'est d'avoir été accompagnée
par une structure d'accompagnement tels
les bg e ou les chambres consulaires ou
autre plateforme d'accompagnement
voilà on voit quelques images pendant
que vous nous présentez ce swing cours
ce sont des candidats de l'édition
précédente si je me trompe pas c'est
pareil c'est dans tous les domaines
quels sont les domaines qui s'en sortent
le mieux qu'en fait il ya six catégories
dans le concours donc chaque catégorie
bas et plus ou moins représentées donc à
une catégorie comme l'artisanat et le
commerce sont les deux catégories où il
ya le plus de personnes qui concourent
on a également une catégorie prestations
de services on a une quatrième catégorie
et surtout ski innovations techniques et
technologiques
on a des catégories nous on y de france
on est très peu concernés mais comme le
le développement rural et et une sixième
catégorie qui est sur l'économie sociale
et solidaire
donc c'est les six catégories donc
chaque chaque entreprise peut concourir
dans la catégorie qui lui correspond
tout à l'heure on parlait du microcrédit
une entreprise qui s'est lancée grâce au
microcrédit vous avez accompagné peu
concours sont visibles tout à fait là
dit fait partie des organisations pagne
mans donc une entreprise accompagné par
l'adip concourir et ils ont plus de
succès de ray plus de succès en général
ou pas parce qu'ils ont été bien
accompagné je pourrais pas vous dire je
sais pas je connais pas les statistiques
des partenaires qui enfin qui accompagne
qui sont lauréats du concours mais en
tout cas ils sont éligibles je crois que
vous avez déjà eu des lauréats chez les
nouveautés voilà pourquoi on est bien
accompagné on peut réussir ensuite
alors si tu as fait justement en fait il
ya donc des lauréats dans chaque région
suite à un concours national donc six
lauréats pour les six catégories
artisanat commerces etc
est ce qu'il ya un yvelinois qui a déjà
gagné ce concours national au niveau
national sur le concours talents
je crois pas en yvelines au niveau
régional farjallah qu'ils ont participé
au niveau régional donc faut savoir que
quand on participe aux régionales et
qu'on gagne
l'aspect régional on est automatiquement
qualifiée en fait pour le concours
national dont concours national faut
savoir que c'est déjà les 20 meilleurs
dans chaque catégorie de la france qui
sont représentés et sur ses vins
malheureusement je dirais qu'il y en a
qu'un donc voilà donc sur les yvelines
les nappes têtu il y en a peut-être eu
mais ça fait ça fait quinze ans que le
concours existe donc j'ai pas j'ai pas
mémoire de sam par contre on a eu des
lauréats régionaux qui ont participé au
concours nationaux dont fabrice le look
et qui est venu qui fait partie du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
qui avait gagné au niveau régional dans
la catégorie services à la personne
voilà on en a eu un deuxième boisé à
pour des constructions en bois qui a
gagné en 2007 aussi le concours régional
on le voit bien ce concours c'est un
moyen d'aider les entrepreneurs mais
vous les idées aussi au quotidien
donc quelles sont les autres moyens que
vous utilisez à la bce
alors nous on a un organisme
d'accompagnement à la création
d'entreprise donc l'accompagnement à la
création d'entreprise ça va de
l'adéquation porteurs de projets projet
de l'étude de marché
l'aspect financier le montage du
business plan jusqu'à l'aspect juridique
du projet donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
plus de l'accompagnement individuel pour
chacun des projets et on fait également
des formations spécialisées en fonction
de chaque porteur de projet de ce qu'il
a besoin comme des formations
spécifiques sur de la comptabilité de la
gestion sûre du marketing
voilà on fait un peu de tout le monde
essaye de les former au maximum en fait
sur tout les tout ce que doit avoir
toutes les compétences car chef
d'entreprise va voir on a vu tout à
l'heure la dit s'adresse à des gens qui
sont exclues financièrement
économiquement
est-ce que vous avez les mêmes profils
alors nous reçoit tout type de personnes
implantée sur les yvelines quel que soit
son projet quelques quelles que soient
ses caractéristiques
donc on peut recevoir des personnes
issues du rsa on peut recevoir des
personnes reconnues travailleurs
handicapés
on peut recevoir des demandeurs d'emploi
tout comme des salariés donc on reçoit
vraiment tout type de personne alors
c'est le 20ème anniversaire je pense là
déjà dans les yvelines
votre anniversaire mais est-ce que vous
avez une idée du nombre d'entreprises
qui a été créée ou suivis dans votre
institution
alors on a reçu alors on a accueilli un
peu près quinze mille personnes depuis
depuis bientôt vingt ans et on a
accompagné à peu près 8000 8000
personnes 8000 projets et sur à peu près
les 8000 projets accompagnés je dirais
qu'il ya à peu près un quart qui ont
réellement créés et vos prévisions pour
les 20 prochaines années
ça va continuer sur le même rythme je
pense que ça va augmenter parce qu'au
début la bce il ya vingt ans il y avait
un ou deux conseillers maintenant on une
dizaine donc forcément je pense qu'il ya
du potentiel
puis vu la crise économique je pense car
à plus en plus de personnes qui
s'orienteront vers la vers la création
d'entreprise pour créer son propre
emploi il développé ses propres
compétences merci d'être venu nous
présenter donc ce concours on rappelle
peut-être les modalités et les dates
ça se déroule quand comment ça se passe
alors donc semaine donc du microcrédit
qui se passe du 4 au 10 février avec
donc une action à la chambre des métiers
jeudi jeudi 5 février de 13h30 à 16h30
ça y est donc concours des talents qui
est déjà ouvert qui est ouvert depuis le
2 janvier on peut s'inscrire en ligne
jusqu'au 30 avril
merci merci à vous trois on passe à
présent aux infos en plus de ce 31
janvier est claire oui alors elles
influent plus concerne le groupe virgin
nous patrick zelnik le pdg du label
indépendant naïve et candidat à la
reprise de virgin megastore demandent
l'aide de l'état c'est pour lui seul
moyen d'assainir les comptes du groupe
est de sauver le magasin des
champs-elysées
le gouvernement n'a pas encore répondu à
cette annonce mais christine mondolot la
présidente actuelle de virgin l'a fait
pour elle cette offre de reprise et
médiatique et n'est pas viable
économiquement
pour le moment donc le sort des salariés
de virgin reste incertain on rappelle
quand même qu à montigny le bretonneux
le bretonneux pardon une quarantaine de
personnes sont concernées
et puis cette autre information
économique elle concerne le groupe eads
également planté dans les yvelines
mais alors est-ce qu'on verra à le ver
jean à la présidence d'honneur de ads
c'est un scénario de plus en plus
crédible puisque l'ancien président se
dit je directoire d'areva pardon
et jean claude trichet ancien président
de la bce vous représenter les intérêts
de l'état au conseil d'administration du
groupe européen d'aéronautique
la décision sera tout de même clairement
acté après l'accord de l'assemblée
générale d' eads en mars eads qui donc
un groupe présent dans les épinards il
encourt avec sa branche astrium la
chiffres du chômage pour terminer
presque une bonne nouvelle dans le
département presque on va terminer oui
avec les chiffres du chômage le nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi dans les yvelines
a tout de même augmenté de 0,4 pour cent
sur le mois de décembre sur le reste de
la france
on a connu une hausse de 0,1 pour cent
ça représente 300 personnes c'est la
hausse la plus faible de l'année mais ça
reste tout de même le vingtième mois
consécutif d'augmentation du chômage
quelques dates à présent on termine
cette chronique de l'écho avec l'agent
dame tout à fait à retenir donc cette
semaine la nuit de l'orientation qui
aura lieu demain à la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
ça se passe de 16 heures à 20 heures au
programme des tests des vidéos des
rencontres avec des professionnels tout
un programme
toujours dans le domaine de
l'orientation nous avons le forum
intercommunal des métiers et de
l'orientation
ça se déroulera samedi 9 février à la
salle des fêtes de la ferme de la
tramblais à bois d'arcy
c'est ouvert à tout public de 10h à 16h
trépied on parlait de concours tout à
l'heure
tout à fait on parlait concours un autre
s'ouvre du 11 février jusqu'au 22 avril
il s'agit cette fois du concours de la
création et du développement de la jeune
entreprise
alors il rêva récompenser ceux qui sont
porteurs de projets qui viennent de
lancer ou même de reprendre une
entreprise pour les meilleurs projets
donc s'est organisé pour la maison notre
part la maison de l'entreprise avec ses
partenaires le prix c'est tout de même
50 mille euros ça peut valoir le coup
alors pour ceux qui veulent plus
d'informations rendez vous sur le site
de l'agglomération
merci claire et rendez vous donc jeudi
prochain aux mêmes heures pour cette
chronique de l'écho on passe au rappel
des titres à présent les sujets que nous
avons développé ce soir en images la
mobilisation des agents de la fonction
publique dans l'éducation nationale un
mouvement peu suivi dans les yvelines
seulement 18% de grévistes
elle nous avons fait le point ce soir
dans l'agglomération est la france a
remporté le bocuse d'or 2013 ces jeux
olympiques de la cuisine cette olympiade
avec le trophée empoché partie
beaucoup de jiri le chef adjoint de la
création salé chez lenôtre à plaisir en
football 32e de finale de la coupe de
france les féminines de montigny
sèchement battu par le psg 9 à 0 logique
respectée
les filles se concentre maintenant sur
leur championnat pour un maintien en 2e
division et la sphère gaston dominici
revue et peut être corrigé par des
étudiants en droit de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'association juris tribune propose tous
les ans ces reconstitutions de procès
historique et ce sera demain au tribunal
de grande instance à versailles à partir
de 12h30 si vous venez de nous rejoindre
sur tv fils thibault ruggieri et donc
pour deux ans le nouveau champion du
monde de cuisine il a 30 ans il exerce à
plaisir auprès de lenôtre sa réaction
depuis à lyon où se déroulait la
compétition
champion olympique de cuisine c'est
ainsi que l'on peut appeler aujourd'hui
thibault ruggeri chef adjoint de la
création salé chez lenôtre à plaisir qui
vient de décrocher le bocuse d'or
c'était ce mercredi soir à lyon et ce
jeudi matin au téléphone la voix un peu
éraillée par la nuit qu'il vient de
passer et que l'on devine longue
thibault ruggieri savoure son prix c'est
important de faire la fête avec les
compatriotes et tous les candidats et
tous ceux qui ont cru qu'ils ne l'ont
supporté le cuir vieilli terre sur des
photos des interviews et autres choses
mais ça fait partie du deal donc fait
une immense joie une immense fierté
sachant qu'il y avait une grosse
responsabilité de représenter la france
donc vraiment extrêmement contents et
énormément d'émotion pour pour moi et
toute l'équipe qui était de chez lenôtre
avec qui je sais les flammes aidés d'une
manière exceptionnelle
cette compétition du bocuse d'or existe
depuis 1987 elle réunit tous les deux
ans 24 chefs du monde entier qui vous
redire et à remporter ce prix sous les
yeux de son coach fabrice prochasson le
jeune homme a découvert la cuisine à
l'âge de 11 ans en inventant comme il
l'a appelé son gâteau poubelle une sorte
de quatre-quarts une inventivité aux
apparences tout simple qu'il a donc mené
aujourd'hui au sommet le dernier bocuse
d'or pour la france remonte à 2007
fendue 7,8 pour ce 31 janvier rendez
vous lundi 18h nouvelle et dit
sion en direct proposé par l'ensemble de
la rédaction et demain vous avez rendez
vous avec catherine plateau pour
l'édition du week-end excellente soirée
à lundi